you know french fries are deep-fried and
they're really unhealthy and we should
probably make you many of them yes we're
gonna need a lot of them I know yeah
hi everybody this is our second
challenge that's what it was the
blindfolded cereal challenge what are we
doing today
why are you full this french fry
challenge key thing can be eating hey go
to school I think you're really hard
sure you know your french fries that
well yeah I think I might know
McDonald's that's it well yeah I see
yeah I think you'd be hard throwing some
french right a exact same all right so
the way it is blindfolded french fry
challenge is going to work is we're
gonna be blindfolded like this and then
mommy here well come bring out the
fridge rice we eat one or two and try to
guess which fry is which from a
fast-food restaurant should we do catch
up for no ketchup
look at you no ketchup really yes
because uh if you french fries with
ketchup and your containers start
guessing there can be high high high
times every single time huh oh it isn't
mr. Cleg height just gonna overpower the
french fries bargaining taste is ketchup
now yeah so it's the bit to do it
properly we got to only eat the french
fries all right bring on number one oh
can you see No all right Brianna number
one Mona
[Music]
number one
french fries number one smelled like
french bread yeah oh you're eating one
already
that's what Cheers hmm oh I know this
one who has the famous taste College in
here I don't think so wait it's a
country to me it tastes like that one
taste that I will know
hot or cold fresh or old oh yes yes I
know this what is it Nick I shall ensure
this my song against you of soul peace
oh yes Harry really I went to LA Japan
like a year ago we were eating
McDonald's not there to see it with any
different the French fries are way way
soft here mm-hmm
this is very good I'm pretty sure is
McDonald McDonald yeah all right
McDonald easy
I'd rather get harder dope yep this is
the only one I think I know Holly I say
anymore
thanks guys - number two where is it
mmm ooh he's so weird not what I was
expecting
wait I think these these are burger king
farouk a floor I put this and we don't
like it you don't like it you know I
pasty but I put Burger King doesn't have
curly fries
these are curly fries now they're in a
circle Oh Kyle jr. how are you
yeah good fun yeah basic I can't mistake
this one either actually you know why
what I grew up next to one of these
places and I used to go here all the
time
breaking nope hard biz Oh darbie
yeah I think it's are these trends your
answer now yeah I need a roast goose now
I should go with this one
right number three three and my hands
are covered in salt are yours
No are you been licking them yeah you're
eating them already yeah and you go to
dig in fact this is a this is a
complicated one
I think it's water boiler not only knows
water burgers out here in California no
how I know what fries these are no jr.
actually you know what on second thought
maybe I don't know I'm gonna say cuz I
don't like them
there's only one place I don't like
french fries from in the birthday scene
you don't work no here you know I don't
like after no eating like five movies no
they don't taste like in a not anymore
oh man it's hard mmm they're just so
delicious
yeah this delicious it doesn't always in
and out right watch it be in and out and
like I do like you know I think it's
like 32 there's Burger King I want to
call junior so I actually have no idea
what when you french fries roll because
I don't have ever go to one do this
anymore
absolutely just a jacket bucks as I'm
walking I Missoula deer choice Jack in a
box yeah I have no idea
this one's confusing okay definitely not
Anna now yeah definitely
right number for micro structures
agitate what role are you already 80
these are dick these are borderline
potato wedges what serves french fries
nice big oh wait I think that might know
what I'm try again let me try again
I don't eat french fries that often
anymore because I'm trying to be healthy
eating and I swear to you I think I
think these places like changing their
recipes I don't recognize this this is
bland I feel like it's Burger King
I don't remember you making big french
fries like this but you know what
reminds me working from this hole the
Chris penis the way it feels on the
outside of you just feel it
copy you started working I think this is
a car with previous gosh you're doing
anything close to this
you know laughing Mesa was uh we did
last one was or getting to do I think
weeds across your last time no last time
Oh at last time yeah I think we said
jazz and works oh no we're gonna
computers no not let's just focus on
this one right now this one right now
this is a Popeye's quick my Popeyes
assessment friends well you know
anything is what Taco Bell
mmm talk about french fries would be
pretty interesting I would say I think
I'm at the Gerber thing because you know
why the aftertaste it has a Burger King
flavor to it these were nice
alright Wendy's Burger King expert I see
right number five me ask so much salt in
my fingers that thing I could just
sprinkle some salt on their french fries
are sharing you know what the French
fries on yeah
Oh in and out dine in Ojai no I know in
and out fries always hold always cold
feels like cardboard tastes like
cardboard mmm tastes bad okay back to
you he's kind of good do you like
getting cardboard what how does it taste
like cardboard the only thing a changing
table morning she tries soaps the
moisturizer yeah I think we need some
soda yeah anyway you know what I don't
like it you know yeah I agree
in and out yeah do not like take it away
dump it in the trash
alright I think an edit okay
alright number six
look six in Chinese or in Cantonese have
natives look oh goodness this is
confusing
oh you know what I tell you so it's
different about this one so far I can
take the skin yes who had researched
potato skins on their own tribes I have
so spooked on this challenge is getting
harder and harder now I'm getting really
confused in my own head thank you since
I can't see anything I just have a whole
bunch of bad food logo is going through
my head
you ever looked at the billboards when
we drive yes okay you ever noticed
jack-in-a-box
billboards I feel like they serve french
fry the skin me do they
am I am I am I gonna over here no my
real oh I knew a franchisor loves me
hard he can be yeah yeah this is hard
yes this is very very hard but another
person got right this one let's just say
I'm not thinking about when I say
already things are going to can give me
Sabre I don't know you know what if you
said birthing for all of them you're
bound to get one right I'm pretty sure
everything than I mean you can't you
can't have a French by challenge without
me I tried so just say birthing for all
them you're going to get one right
Frankie
is very good you know uh I feel like it
Carlos and jr.
I'm pretty sure I'm gonna stick with
Jack in the Box you go Carson here
Jack about Carl jr. next next please
number seven number seven I'm getting
thirsty again our city which is that
some drinks to go with it we haven't
actually joked it that's okay there's a
lot more over here I think we're oh my
god take like the one brush from before
Oh neat mommy's playing a trick on us
yeah it tastes like the one between all
our tastes different
oh no no clue I'm drawing a blank here
this could be rulers french fries ever
gone are Wiener schnitzel whoa excuse me
order it's probably in Korea chief it
will be funny if all to Burger King he
said it was actually not breaking this
was completely Burger King I mean the
more we can guising the more confused
beginning they all start taking the same
french fries or french fries right yep
I'm pretty thirsty I know could you
drink a bottle of ketchup right now you
know get you right about now it sounds
pretty good
yeah all right let's go with uh did I
say Wendy's dead I don't know
Wendy's I don't know yeah I'm gonna
finger face when do you feel all right
this is Wendy you're next
[Music]
number eight oh I'm so holding about the
French rep and last one
mmm don't know all right we should have
had soda you know why cleanse our
palates now every French fry case is
saying you know what this one is in and
out in and out take place yeah no good
you lit it up yeah it's enough high five
high five
yeah hey what are you doing why are you
doing it the one thing I can't do
blindfolded is tickle you all right I
think you know yeah take it away it's no
good and it now definitely needs ketchup
yeah three then you know I know what it
tastes like it's uh potato chips
yeah it's Lay's and then you just cut
the lace and then make it into a wool
and then put everything into like a
little quad rail quadrilateral yeah
freeze it I mean haughtiness or plenty
of and there's any make it sounds good
mmm yeah all right
oh right I get my hand
oh wait green button I didn't lick it
once all yours is pretty good
you think too long you this whole time
this is the aftermath the French fry
challenge I licked my hands so W will
look like II got touched my friend track
all right how did you think you do I I
think I did like the lowered sport you
know what since I'm pretty sure I did
pretty bad you think you did pretty bad
let's have a competition for the lowest
score ever
yeah I think I got to say so you go on
okay let's do it
what are the answers moment all right so
for the first one you both get the ball
[Music]
and you gotta move it yes yeah
Mardis anyone you guys both get RV and
you both got it right
yeah sure yeah
he's two for two for the third one you
both get jack-in-the-box
but it was Wendy
no okay or the fourth one I would get
20k pika 13 KP got it right whispers yes
thank you happy for me
no because the war store oh well I'm
playing a different game now I'm playing
the high score oh yeah we're playing
let's go a little score okay okay all
right yeah get more right Isaac come on
come on come on for the first one
both of you get in and help but it was
Lena Central Americans also want to be
in and out for number six
hmm I forget Carl's jr. Casey just check
the box eyes we got it right yeah I'm
talking about how I died for number
seven
you're both s when you and you both get
it wrong contain my knees and jackin a
buck really hard to figure out and for
the last one
both of you get in and out and you go
cut it right yeah
Ty Ty four four four four mmm hey nice
thank you bad we thought we're going to
do really really really bad hi guys
thank you for watching our video the
second challenge with the blindfolded
french-fried cheering let us know in the
comments below if you want us to do
other challenges like always please
subscribe down there and leave a thumbs
up down there please or as reported by I
thank you for watching
bye thank you
[Music]